you can't pop your own pimple i want you
to pop your pimples thinking that you
have a hot date
in a half an hour acne breakouts only
happen on your face
not true face mapping can identify the
cause of your acne
this is not like reading your palm hello
everyone my name is dr love
i'm a board certified dermatologist in
new york city
i've been practicing for about five
years and i specialize in both
medical and aesthetic dermatology my
name is josh zeikner
i'm a board-certified dermatologist and
an associate professor of dermatology at
mount sinai hospital in new york city
and i specialize in the treatment of
acne rosacea and cosmetic dermatology
and today we will be debunking myths
about
acne eating greasy food causes acne
so theoretically if you're eating very
greasy food and then you're immediately
like wiping your face and with your
hands you can clog your pores but for
most people if you're eating your food
you're washing your hands you're having
good hygiene
it's unlikely that the greasiness of the
actual food that you're eating
is going to have an effect on your skin
instead it's the sugary food
we know that foods that have a high
glycemic index
cause acne breakouts in some people and
it's thought that raising blood sugar
promotes inflammation and drives oil
production
so when you go to the restaurant to go
buy your
milkshake and your burger it's not the
burger but rather the bun and the
milkshake
that are causing breakouts i in general
tell my patients that by following
a general healthy diet you're also
following
a healthy diet for your acne if you
drink eight glasses of water a day
you'll have clear skin
okay well hydrated for our overall
health but it is completely a myth that
you need to drink eight glasses of water
for hydrated skin
let alone clear skin there's no data
showing that drinking fewer than eight
glasses of water is associated
with dry skin or acne breakouts either i
do think it matters
what you eat what you drink i think it
matters
what your exercise routine is and i
think it matters what your topical
routine and maybe even your
by mouth routine it's by your
dermatologist all of these things
are factors that contribute to our acne
but there's no kind of magic cure that
just drinking water will cure your acne
the only time i have found that water
clears up your acne
is when you're using that water to
swallow your prescription acne
medication that your dermatology given
you in the office
acne breakouts only happen on your face
not true acne breakouts are definitely
more common on the face but we also know
that they can occur on the chest
the shoulder the back and then you can
even get acne like breakouts on the
scalp
acne develops in areas where we have a
high concentration of oil glands also
known as sebaceous glands
the most common reason that i see acne
on the body
is sweat related acne so for this type
of acne
making a habit of changing out of sweaty
clothing and maybe even using
an acne fighting body wash after
workouts can really help acne on the
body
isn't always actually true acne i know
that everybody talks about
buttony or butt well guess what butt
acne
usually is not even acne it's
folliculitis which is a little infection
a hair follicle and that happens when
your skin barrier is disrupted and
bacteria on the skin
make its way into the hair follicles
people typically develop
red bumps and pus pimples if you don't
have any
big nodules if you don't have any
blackheads or whiteheads
then you may have folliculitis face
mapping can identify the cause of your
acne
everybody loves a good story on the
internet saying that if you have acne in
one particular area
that i can tell you exactly what causes
it this is not like reading your
palm unfortunately there's no definitive
way
of mapping the cause of your acne based
on where it's developing now that being
said
we know that adult women tend to develop
acne
along the lower one-third of the face
and the jawline
we know that hair care products are
associated with acne breakouts
along the hairline on the upper part of
the face and sometimes
if you are using a dirty phone or if you
have a
chin strap or a face mask you may be
developing
acne in areas where those are directly
coming in contact with your skin
but other than that there's not much
science to face mapping
acne can be asymmetric and so i have
patients who will have more acne on one
side than
of their face than the other side and
they will drive themselves crazy
trying to figure out what specifically
is causing the acne and
it's just how we're made think of your
face as having thousands of pipes
connecting your oil glands to the
surface of the skin in patients who have
acne all of those pipes are somewhat
clogged the problem is
we can't predict which one will become
clogged enough to form a full pimple
so when we treat acne we really want to
address the entire area that tends to
break out to get rid of pimples that we
have
and to prevent new pimples from popping
up if you don't get acne during puberty
you won't get it as an adult it's
completely a myth that you're free from
acne if you didn't have it during
puberty
acne most commonly develops during
puberty
and in adolescence and for most people
it goes away but there's a subset of
patients who actually had clear skin as
a teenager
and then sometime around the age of 25
or older start to break out
but it may have to do with changes in
hormones
diet or stress many adult women who are
developing acne actually have dry skin
which
complicates the way that we treat the
acne sometimes adult acne particularly
that
deeper acne can be resistant to topical
therapies and that's when we consider
by mouth options my preference is
there is a hormonally based medication
called spironolactone that
is highly effective for adult onset acne
particularly the hormonal driver for the
acne
bad hygiene causes acne there's
no data to support that it's a hygiene
problem that's causing acne we know that
acne
is a really complicated medical disorder
with
a complicated pathophysiology not at all
related to hygiene
but this is also can be a damaging myth
because i find that a lot of my acne
patients what they try to do
is they try to over cleanse their skin
and essentially
when you start scrubbing your skin and
over cleansing your skin you
increase inflammation at the level of
the skin
and at the end of the day acne is an
inflammatory condition but for the most
part the people who are most at risk
are people who have oily and acne prone
skin to begin with
if someone else's acne treatment works
for them
then it'll work for me some people with
acne have oily skin some people with
acne have
dry skin some people with acne have
sensitive skin
some people cannot remember to use a
topical for the life of them
some people prefer by mouth medications
and so
there are a multitude of different ways
to treat acne and the one that will work
is one the medications that are designed
to treat the type of acne that you have
but also
to the medications that will actually
fit into your life
and your lifestyle masturbation causes
acne
i have no idea where this comes from i i
i honestly know is the answer to it but
i would love to know
dr zeitner do you know like where the
origin of this is
i'm not really sure is it because
teenagers get acne but i actually would
think
that masturbating might help clear up
your acne
stress relief right but there's no data
to show that
masturbating will or will not affect
your skin at all
you can't pop your own pimple if you pop
your pimple
the right way it's okay with me but the
problem is
most people are not doing that patients
often try to pop like the super inflamed
pimples which just
sometimes don't want to be drained and
sometimes the best way to treat those
is with actually an anti-inflammatory in
office
and so don't try it it may cause more
scarring it may cause more trouble
if you're going to pop something it
really needs to be
blackheads number one don't do it at
night
that's when you're tired and you're
going to bed i want you to pop your
pimples thinking that you have a hot
date
in a half an hour and your face needs to
look good because if you think about it
that way
you're not going to put too much
pressure on your skin you want to make
sure that the skin is clean
and your fingers are clean and you can
take two cotton tip applicators like
q-tips
and just apply gentle downward and
inward pressure around the pimple
and if you're trying too hard and
they're not coming out then leave it
alone and abort the mission
putting toothpaste on your pimple will
make it go away
toothpaste was formulated with a
preservative known as triclosan
and this was an ingredient that helped
prevent bacterial contamination
and because it has antimicrobial
properties that's where
or why toothpaste was originally used to
treat temples but guess what
as it turns out triclosan led to a lot
of allergies in the skin
so it's been removed from toothpaste so
the reason that toothpaste was being put
on the pimples isn't even there anymore
and it contains harsh ingredients with
an alkaline ph the hydrogen peroxide
baking soda and all of these things will
dry out your pimple
but it's also going to dry out your skin
in general and cause a whole big mess
but the reality is that toothpaste was
not designed to be used on your face and
they're much
more effective acne fighting ingredients
that can be used in the same manner
my personal favorite is benzoyl peroxide
as a spot treatment
to both dry out the acne decrease the
inflammation
and decrease any microbial or bacterial
growth
aspirin will help get rid of breakouts
we take
aspirin all the time to help treat a
fever because it has anti-inflammatory
properties
it's actually made up of an ingredient
that's similar to salicylic acid
which is a really commonly used
treatment for acne because it helps
remove
excess oil and dead cells from the
surface of the skin to dry out the
pimple
even though they're cousins aspirin does
not have those same effects in the skin
instead of using aspirin i would
recommend actually using
salicylic acid as a spot treatment or
benzoyl peroxide as a spot treatment and
if you're looking for something natural
then a cool compress is an easy option
acne always goes away on its own about
85 of people between the ages of 7 to 24
will develop acne to the point where we
almost consider it something called
physiologic so for the majority of those
people
their acne will resolve with their
teenage years
but there is a large number of people
where their acne does not
self-resolve even acne that goes away
within the teenage years can sometimes
leave behind
scars that can be permanent i recommend
treating your acne
when it gets to a point where it bothers
you emotionally or physically
because those emotional or physical
scars
are permanent and stick with you for the
rest of your life so
if you're suffering from breakouts and
you're trying over-the-counter products
and they're not helping
make sure to visit a board-certified
dermatologist like myself for dr love
because that's what we're here to do to
help treat your pimples
josh i'm never doing a video with you
again you're like a super pro
oh my god no you are awesome this was
great